I understand and agree with all your
thoughts and principles. However,
however I interpret your concepts for
leaders leading men were mostly driven or
other leaders who have a desire to make
themselves better in maintaining the
status. Yup. So common misperception,
right? Is that, you know
the military and the seals,
I see this all time. Everyone thinks
that the military in the seals,
I think that we're leading
terminator robots, right?
And everyone is just driven
and they're going to get up.
They're going to do everything.
And it's,
I just talked about this on the
last podcast. It is a bell curve.
It is a bell curve and there's a great
bunch of guys at the top of the bell
curve that are go getters. There's a
solid bunch of guys in the middle of it.
It is the lower guys that are bumps.
And so this interpretation that the
concepts that I talk about are just for
leading these front,
running a personalities that
just make everything happen.
N Not correct.
You know,
there are seals that don't want to work.
There are seals that
want to take shortcuts.
There are seals that want to
skate by then you get outside,
then you're working with Iraqi soldiers
that are unmotivated, untrained,
poorly equipped. We got to work
with these guys. We got bosses.
I mean I've got bosses in the seal teams
that are either an egomaniac or that
are old, true risk averse. You could
have any of this stuff going on.
You can have your guys
that are risk averse.
You can have guys that are too crazy.
You got all, you know what they are.
They're humans, they're
individuals, they're human beings.
And because they're human beings, even in
special operations, and sometimes it is,
especially in in special operations,
cause when you get in special operations,
you could guys that have huge
egos and attitudes and so,
oh you think that they just want to
do whatever you tell them to do? No,
they got their own idea.
They got to call their own method.
They got their own plan.
They got their own, what?
They think they're a tactical genius.
So you got to get around that.
So what does it mean?
It means you have to lead them.
And it's the common theme that
I'm talking about all the time.
And what does that mean?
You've got to build relationships,
you've got to build the trust,
you've got to make sure they understand
why they're doing what they're doing.
You've got to make sure they
understand the strategic and back.
You got to empower them. You gotta set a
good example. You gotta listen to them.
You got to take input, you got
to give them responsibility. And,
and when I say responsibility,
I mean real responsibility.
You've got to build them up.
You got to make them better.
You gotta show them and let them see.
Not In a, not in a, in your face way,
but you've got to subtly let them see
what self improvement means to them and
how they can better their position
and what drive we'll get them.
You got to give them ownership of stuff
and you've got to let that ownership
grow into extreme ownership where
they really want to own things.
You got to teach them to lead and you've
got to put them in leadership positions
and you've got to show your trust by
actually following them. Sometimes
and again, people ask me these
questions, you know how I'm a new leader?
How do I lead? I got a new person. How
do I lead them? It's the same answers.
It's the same answers all the time.
The principles of leadership.
Now the nuances are there.
Yes,
the nuances are there and I have to nuance
for echo that I got a nuance for this
guy over here and I got to New
Orleans for this group over here.
The the nuances are there, but the basic
principles are the same. Am I never,
am I going to?
Who am I going to be in charge of that?
I'm not going to try and build a
relationship of trust with them. Who?
Who's that dancers? Nobody. You know?
Who is it that I don't want to set?
A good example for the answer is nobody.
Who is it that I'm not going to listen to?
If you don't listen to people,
you alienate them. You don't want
to be part of the team. I mean it's,
if the things are universal,
and again,
there's nuances because you might have to
make adaptations. And you know, when we,
when we did battle
leadership with, uh, with uh,
Adolf von Shell and he talks about
distinctly these three different types of
commanders and how the boss gave them
each their own little adjusted order
because he was dealing with
their personalities. So yes,
you've got to deal with the personalities,
but that doesn't mean you're doing
something different from the principals.
So
when you get, sure, when you get
to the bottom of the bell curve,
you might see some people that
might need to be replaced.
They might need to be removed,
but I'll tell you what,
most likely they just need to be led.
Mm.
The reason that our,
I think one of the reasons why it,
the perception is that all your
guys are robots and you know,
I'm going to give you an order. They
follow it. No questions that is,
is like movies, right? Like a few good
men membered Jack Nicholson. He's like,
people will follow orders or people die.
That was his thing.
And they say that kind of
stuff. Yeah. And but they do,
they do capture it in some Hollywood
movies where they show how mutinies take
place and how things go
wrong and how, you know, the,
the new lieutenant Vietnam is going
to get fragged by his own people.
That stuff's real. Yeah.
You know, that stuff's real.
So it's just, it, it's, it's
a misperception. The other,
the other misperception is because of
boot camp, a lot of military movies are,
they show up, they show a significant
amount of time in bootcamp,
but bootcamp is a matter of
weeks in a career. You know,
I think the Marine Corps
bootcamp is 13 weeks.
I think the army bootcamp is 10 weeks.
Bootcamp is a very short period of time
in your four year, six year, eight year,
10 year, 20 year career
bootcamp is, you know,
I talked about the indoctrinational
times in the military.
They have very short periods of
time compared to your whole career.
And in bootcamp when your drill
instructor says dropdown and do pushups,
you drop down and do pushups in bootcamp
when you're Joan instructor says,
pickup that, you know, make your
bed, you make your bed when these,
and if you don't,
they yell at you and they yell at
you until you do make your bed.
So people get that idea that that's
the way the military is run. Yeah.
And that is like, you know, a great
example is full metal jacket than movie,
which is a great movie.
But the boot camp scene is half the movie.
But in reality, even if you are
a guy in, in Vietnam, you know,
boot campus 13 weeks and then you
went onto, into Vietnam for a year.
So it's a fraction of what
your real career is like. And,
and so people get that impression that
you're just going to be able to bark
orders. Everyone's gonna listen to you.
It just doesn't work that way. Yeah.
And there's actually, there's a
great, there's a great video. Um,
it's called Charlie
Company and V, uh, anyways,
I forget the name of the video,
but it's about a company in Vietnam,
Charlie Company. And maybe if you
remind me, I'll put it on the,
on the website. Um, it shows
two company commanders.
But anyways, to make a long
story short, these guys,
they don't like their
new company commander.
And at first they're resistant to
him and you know, he says, listen,
these guys could go to learn that there's
going to have to do. And I tell him,
and then it fast forwards a couple months
and they interview him again and he
goes, hey, you know, how's
everything going? He goes, you know,
they get it now and they realize that
they just had to listen to me and do what
I told them.
And then they go out in the field with
the guys and the guys in the fueled,
they're supposed to be doing things and
they're just not doing, they're just,
they're literally calling back like, yeah,
where did we did, yeah, we did a patrol.
They didn't do it. Yeah,
we moved positions. They
didn't move positions. Yeah.
We're going to do another, you
know, another foot patrol tonight,
they're not doing it.
So he was under the impression that
everyone had like buckled to his will.
They were just completely
snowing him and he had no idea.
So that's what happens in the military.
If you're don't lead your people and
you just order them around and you think
that everyone's just this, this, uh, this,
uh, well, how would they describe it here?
Men who are mostly driven or leaders who
have a desire to make themselves better.
I mean, if anybody in a
position with guys like that,
it's going to the leadership job,
it's going to be very easy.
You just tell them what to do
when they do it. Right. I mean,
I could give you example upon example
upon example of stuff in the seal teams
were what I had to do to get people
convinced that this was the right thing to
deal. You know, I mean, it
is like, you know, a classic
example is telling guys, okay,
we're gonna take Iraqi soldiers
on every operation. You know?
So these guys were saying, are you kidding
me? Well, they just didn't go, hey,
cool Jocko. We'll do exactly
what you tell us. No, they look,
what are you talking about raw taking
these guys out, why would we do that?
It's going to be risky. These guys
aren't trustworthy. They don't,
they're not trained. Right. They had
a million reasons why not to do that.
But how do you get them to do it?
You explain to them why you explained
to them the strategic importance.
You have built trust with them.
You tell them that they're going
to take ownership of the Iraqis.
I mean it's everything that I just said.
That's what you do.
That's a classic example.
So yes,
once again, you have, if you're
in a leadership position,
you have to lead.
You ever seen the movie saving
Private Ryan? Yes. Yeah.
There was a part in then and
that movie that um, that they,
they weren't down for the orders.
Remember that way it was kind of like
a little pivotal part where they were
going to go take a, a machine
gun nest and they were like, man,
we don't have to do this. So they all kind
of got together and said, hey, you know,
seems like unnecessary risks.
And he's like,
he kind of tripped out a little bit and
kind of forced them to do it and they
were like, all right, whatever.
Kind of reluctantly than one of the
guys died and stuff. But anyway,
that's an example of where the,
yeah,
and especially, you know when you were
just doing a talking about world war one,
that one portion of the book
where he says, you know what,
we got ordered to do this thing. I didn't
feel good about it but it was an order,
we're going to do it. So there's
examples from the past, especially where,
you know,
it's definitely was more like that in
the past and bobble on one obviously.
It was like that obviously it was like
that unfortunately it was like that. Yeah.
Because it caused people to continue,
you know,
to execute these operations that
we're just going to get people killed.
And you know, actually Lafe and I
were talking about that last week,
Pickett's charge, get
tickets, charge Gettysburg.
They sent the troops up and they got
slaughtered and they can, you know,
they're survivors came back
in, uh, Lee was, you know,
basically in tears like, Hey, I'm sorry
this happened. I, this was my fault.
He took ownership of it and I hope
I'm getting the story right. Um,
but, but that's the,
that's the general, uh,
the general gist of the
story. But then the, you know,
the big story was that the guys were like,
hey, we'll go again if you, you know,
cause you're such a great leader
will go again. And Life, you know,
was kind of like the know that's what
world war, you know, that's what,
that's what happened. That shows you
that guys were willing and I said,
you have about the differences in
world war one. They sent them again,
they sent them over and over. You
know, Lee was regretting and I'm sorry,
and I did something that got you to
go, you know, a bunch of guys killed.
It's horrible in World War One. And like,
yeah, it happened going again. Yeah.
Oh yeah. And that happens again. We're
doing it again and again and again.
And it's just, uh, I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll always just be horrified
by that and hopefully, um,
man progress's beyond that.
And again,
part of that is as a person
you have to question,
you have to be a rebel.
You have to question what people are
telling you and why they're telling it to
you. If my boss doesn't tell
me why I'm doing my operation,
it's and I continue to execute it, that's
my fault. I need raise my hand and say,
boss of what are we doing? Why are
we doing this? I don't understand.
You got to take that initiative because
if you're just blindly following orders,
I don't want somebody that's
blindly following orders.
I never want people that blindly follow
my orders. I want people that say, oh,
get boss, wait, why are we doing
this? Why is this happening?
Because I want people to,
I want think.
I want leaders underneath me that
know how to lead. And you know what,
when you build the trust and
you build the relationships,
those guys will do anything for you and
my guys. And my task is they do anything.
I mean,
I know it.
They did over and over again did
operations that were crazy and hard and
dangerous and risky. Never
did anyone say odd. You know,
we're not doing this. They said, okay,
we understand. Well, what's the mission?
All right,
so you've got to build that road.
It's against the same basic
principles of leading human beings,
and that's what you gotta do.
But to think that you're just going to
order people to do things, not happening.
Long answer to a, to a good question.
That was actually interesting perspective.
And I know it's a perspective that a
lot of people have. People always think,
well, you know, you led seals and
they're aliens, so that was easy.
But before you said, before you told
me, that's kind of what I figured. Yeah.